good morning it gets Tuesday there's
this WH Auden poem called September 1st
1939 that begins I sit in one of the
dives on 52nd Street uncertain and
afraid as the clever hopes expire of a
low dishonest decade I've always read
that poem as a kind of relic like a
fragment of what life felt like in 1939
as the war in Europe began in a
different phone written around the same
time Auden writes about all the dogs of
Europe barking and each nation being
sequestered in its hate and those
sentiments always felt distant to me
even historical but as we approach
September 1st 2019 80 years since that
poem was set I confess to feeling
uncertain and afraid and like the clever
hopes are expiring of a low dishonest
decade I certainly don't think we're at
imminent risk of the kind of global war
that Auden lived through but in the 41
years I've been around I've never
experienced a now that felt so
precarious and fraught and weird hatred
which has always coerced through the
human story does feel ascendant at the
moment and polarization is worsening and
with it the dangerous dehumanization of
others when we call people trash or
vermin or monsters we edge toward the
great abyss the abyss where we treat
people as trash or vermin or monsters
and I guess I should stop here and
acknowledge that I am hopeful and I
think the data supports my hope like
homicides and violent crime in general
declined in the US and 2018 and in fact
are both lower than they have been in 42
of the last 45 years even after
adjusting for inflation average
household income has risen consistently
over the last decade in the u.s. while
unemployment has consistently declined
but I don't think any of that
invalidates the contemporary horrors I
mean for one thing in the US both
violent crime and unemployment were also
falling during the late 1930s but also
like something is wrong even as humans
are living healthier lives and have
better technologies to connect us we
report on average feeling lonelier than
we did 10 years ago and also less happy
and life expectancy in the u.s. is going
down for the first time in decades
primarily due to substance abuse
disorders and mental health conditions
something is clearly wrong
and maybe part of what makes me feel so
uncertain and afraid is that I don't
know quite what that Auden poem goes on
waves of anger and fear circulate over
the bright and darkened lands of the
earth obsessing our private lives and I
don't know if this is just me but these
days I do sometimes feel like the waves
of anger and fear wash over me with such
force that I am powerless before them
and overwhelmed by them whether it's the
death of a friend or climate change or
mass murder I sometimes feel like I'm an
actor in a play I cannot rewrite lost in
a haunted wood as Auden put it I don't
want you to worry about me I'm fine I
promise
I just don't know how we unwind from
this how do we get out of this strange
labyrinth of terrors and outrages I
don't know but I do believe we will I
believe that one day I will try to
explain to my children why this moment
felt so strange and scary and to them it
will feel like history the most famous
line in that poem is we must love one
another or die and to me that is gospel
truth we must love one another or die
now I know that I'm gonna die but I
truly believe that we are not going to
die I don't know how to move through
this world I don't know all I know is
the last stands of that poem defenseless
under the night our world in stupor lies
yet dotted everywhere ironic points of
light flash out wherever the just
exchanged their messages may I composed
like them of arrows and dust beleaguered
by the same negation and despair show an
affirming flame Hank I'll see you on
Friday